Vivek ramaswamy is the co-founder of
strive asset management and he is a 2024
presidential candidate the following
conversation was recorded at a live
event lyceum Miami which my team and I
hosted on March 4th at the Miami Beach
Convention Center here's my conversation
with Vivek rameshwamy
you have written two different books
yeah and uh those books have become
quite popular I thought a great place to
start would be what is wokeness oh yes
it's good to Define it's good to define
a term so I'll Define it in neutral
terms that are not critical because I
prefer to describe it and then you know
you can either criticize it agree with
it or whatever so wokeness refers to
broadly
seeing invisible injustices that no one
else had previously seen before
becoming alert to them and then taking
all action required to correct those
injustices generally taking the form of
race gender sexual orientation or other
genetically inherited injustices
but now ever expanding to include other
forms of social injustice including the
the most recent secular religion of
climate so that's wokeness in a nutshell
now you can agree with this and believe
that there are systems of of invisible
social hierarchies that have been
created for all of human history and
that it is the job in our moment in
history to correct for all of that in
the present and I think a lot of people
do believe in that I think it's worth
engaging with their ideas seriously and
taking their argument seriously
having tried that set of clothes on you
know a few ideas aren't like your kids
they're like clothes you try them on if
you don't like them you can move on to
the next one uh I prefer to move on to
the next one and that's the camp I am in
with with where the woke movement is but
I think it's become dominant enough in
American life that maybe 20 years ago
this is a fringe philosophy that was
about a challenge to the system and
agree or not I respect anybody who wants
to boldly challenge a prevailing
Orthodoxy there's something about that
you got to respect
but I think what began as a challenge to
the system has now in many ways become
the system in many institutions from
education to even Corporate America in
ways that demand a new challenge to that
system and that's what I tried to do
with my first book woke Inc so there's
this intersection of wokeness with
Society for the way it impacts
individuals there is a interaction with
government and then there's an internet
interaction with corporations
um when you and I first met you were
very focused on that Corporation and how
it was uh interacting with these ideas
of wokeness and
um its mandate to make profits for
shareholders explain what's happened
over the last couple of years how have
these corporations changed and and why
is it that you deem it as such a threat
to the corporation and kind of that
mandate for profits to embrace some of
these ideas yeah I think it's not only a
threat to corporations I think it is a
threat to the Integrity of
self-governance but that sounds dramatic
until you actually see what's going on
so actually it goes back not just a
couple of years but to the 2008
financial crisis so I got my first job
at a hedge fund in the fall of 07 right
on the eve of the 08 crisis and that was
actually quite educational I had a front
row seat to watch that play out the fun
Network for god mentioned in Michael
Lewis's book The Whole Nine Yards it was
it was pretty good experience for me
what happened in the aftermath of the 08
crisis was that
you know the old left was frustrated I
think a lot of us were frustrated with
the use of public funds to bail out
Banks when times went bad even though
the private owners of those Banks made
out well when times were good that was
crony capitalism I I disagree with the
bailouts and the Occupy Wall Street
movement was the response to it so what
Occupy Wall Street said is if you're
going to just run this crony capitalist
show the whole time all the way down
then we're gonna come in and say we're
gonna redistribute that money from those
wealthy corporate Fat Cats to poor
people to help poor people because if
the game is broken then we might as well
play that game and make sure we're
playing it even-handedly
agree or not that's what the old left
had to say
but there was a little bit of
hooks right so this this beginnings of
the woke narrative were also on the rise
right around that same time you know
Barack Obama was elected as first black
president United States there was
different cultural currents converging
in the United States even on the left
and there was the birth of this new
movement that said you know what the the
real problem guys in intra Progressive
conversation here the real problem
wasn't economic Injustice or poverty
quite it was racial Injustice and
misogyny and bigotry and the beginnings
of climate change
and then Wall Street spotted this Rift
and what they said is okay good this is
an opportunity because Occupy Wall
Street is a pretty tough pill to swallow
if you're a big Bank
but the new woke stuff is actually
pretty easy you applaud diversity and
inclusion you put some token minorities
on your boards you Muse about the
racially disparate impact of climate
change after you fly in a private jet to
Davos
it's pretty good work if you can get it
but they didn't do it for free the
implicit expectation was that the new
Left looked the other way when it came
to leaving existing power structure
intact Silicon Valley did the same thing
by the way when it came to censoring
hate speech or misinformation the old
left used to be the one that said break
up big Tech they said wait wait a minute
here we will use our Monopoly power to
advance your ends through censoring
speech and misinformation or hate speech
whatever you want to call it however you
define it will be on your side
but we don't do it for free we expect
the new Left to look the other way when
it comes to the attack on Monopoly power
and so so that's that was really the
beginnings of this it's a sort of
arranged marriage right not an arranged
marriage of love
it's more like Mutual prostitution
the bed fellows don't love each other
but each side gets something out of the
trade and then that was the birth of
this otherwise bizarre occurrence of of
how capitalists get in bed with a bunch
of woke Millennials and they both
capitalism they use that to put Occupy
Wall Street up for adoption that was
actually what set this into motion the
beginning of the ESG movement
can't beat can't beat him join them both
sides kind of have that surrealization
and and then and then it Stanley became
a crescendo from there Trump was elected
that was a catalyst that drove a lot of
people crazy still does to this day as
best I can tell
2018 he pulls out of the Paris climate
Accords that then creates a new sense of
panic that if private sector leaders are
not going to tackle the existential
challenges of global climate change then
if the public sector leaders aren't
going to do it then we in the private
sector have to step up to that challenge
ourselves and then that really throw
through kerosene on what was already a
burning fire turning the ESG movement
into really I think the prevailing
Orthodoxy in American capitalism and so
that's why you know very few people who
are in the position that I was I mean I
was founded built a multi-million dollar
biotech company other Enterprises as
well successful careers hedge fund
partner whatever before you're supposed
to shut up sit down do as you're told
keep making your money and uh and and
move along with it that's that was the
environment certainly when I stepped
down from my job as CEO in uh in January
of 2021 it was a little over a couple
years ago
but I think that the right answer to a
culture of fear is to actually just
start talking openly unapologetically
and you know fear is infectious
but as I you know as I often quip
courage can be contagious too it just
has a higher activation energy it takes
more of us doing it and so that was the
beginning of my journey out of Biotech
into this new world that I've been in
even even pre-presidential campaign
that's the last couple years has been
about about talk about strive and yeah
you guys are getting investors to put
Capital into funds those funds from a
structural standpoint exist among many
asset managers but once you have a high
concentration of funds as you do now uh
you all have essentially tried to
weaponize that money in the boardrooms
not for destructive purposes but as a
discipline tool I would use uh the
terminology to keep companies focused on
their Mandate of making profits talk a
little bit as to like what you guys are
doing there and what the responsible
corporations has been yeah sure and so
so as a lead into understand strive I
just want to briefly describe the
problem the strive set out to solve so
this is a firm I founded you know about
a little over a year ago so I left my
wrote these books traveled the country
decided actually there's a problem to be
solved through the market
not through government through the
market where there's three large asset
managers in the United States BlackRock
State Street Vanguard just those three
control about 20 trillion dollars about
as much Capital as the U.S GDP
but they use it
to not only invest and provide passive
investment exposure to the U.S market
but also to vote for policies like
racial Equity audits at Apple and Home
Depot even when the boards of those
companies didn't want to adopt them
scope 3 emissions caps at companies like
Chevron whose boards did not want to
adopt them until majority of
shareholders and shareholders and air
quotes because they're not the actual
Capital owners but they're registered as
the shareholders tell these firms to do
so this is a big problem I was
complaining about it as an author as a
commentator on cable news and traveling
the country and I said you know what
actually begin my career as an
entrepreneur why not just use that
talent and actually try to solve this
problem so I created strive co-founded
it with with uh with actually a full
former High School classmate of mine who
uh is now got a full team building this
Asset Management apparatus in Columbus
Ohio
that had a different Vision that said
it's going to offer those same kinds of
index funds but with a different
shareholder message to the underlying
companies which is to say get out of
politics Focus exclusively on delivering
excellence in your products and services
and yes make money unapologetically by
maximizing value for your shareholders
in the process novel idea who would have
ever thought
and so that's actually generated a lot
of uh controversy but also a lot of
Demand with it I mean strive I think
crossed over half a billion dollars in
AUM just three months after the launch
of its first fund I think it took JP
Morgan over two years to cross a billion
when they first entered the same ETF
business and I think it's actually just
reflects a bottom-up hunger for people
who once they know speaking of waking up
or becoming awakened to Invisible
injustices they wake up to the invisible
Injustice that their own retirement fund
is being used to cause American oil
companies to produce less oil and gas
so that they with the other hand can pay
for more gas at the pump people are
incensed rightly so I mean I think it's
I would go so far as to call it is
definitely the largest fiduciary breach
of the 21st century in dollar
denominated terms I think there's a case
to make that it's the largest scale
financial fraud on the 21st century
you're telling people one thing in fact
you're doing another
at a 20 trillion dollar scale so so what
we do at strive is you know during my
tenure as I stepped down as executive
chairman and I stepped off the board to
pursue the presidential campaign there's
a whole team running it but even during
my time as executive chairman sent
letters to the boards of Chevron Apple
Disney engaged publicly with those
companies uh even actually though the
last week it was funny just yesterday a
little spat with Mark benioff actually
strive had sent a letter to Salesforce
Benny often and they're bored saying
that
Salesforce should knock it off with the
political behaviors the company hasn't
done well a lot of that's attributable
to the culture that this guy at the top
has created
they have they literally host woke
Wednesdays they require employees to
confess that the US is racist and all
kinds of original sins I mean literally
this is part of company sponsored events
there racial hiring quota systems
gender-based hiring quota systems
threatening to pull out of Republican
states if lawmakers don't adopt policies
that Mark benioff agrees with our
shareholder letters say does not to say
to adopt Republican policies instead no
just knock it off with the politics and
then he lashed back yesterday saying
that well now it's clear I'm just a
politician and I said yeah if you want
to actually run for if you actually want
to be a politician try running for
office and actually get your policies
implemented through the front door
instead he's actually serving as a
politician in the guise of a CEO but
using corporate power as a means of
effectuating it and so why is that a
threat to democracy
it's because we made a bargain in 1776
in this country which said that unlike
Old World Europe which settled its
political differences in the backs of
Palace walls with business Elites and
church Elites getting together and
deciding what was best for the masses
we in 1776 said we're going to do it the
other way we're going to leave it to the
citizens of a country to decide for
themselves For Better or Worse how they
address their political differences and
shared Social Challenges
that was the American bargain and so I
the reason I I view this as a threat to
democratic self-governance is not just
what Milton Friedman worried about
which I worry about too is that it
distracts companies from pursuing their
own mission and maximizing profit which
grows the size of the economy and all
that stuff that's that's known
but the invisible part at least it was
invisible when I first started talking
about this three years ago is that it
delegated
the political decisions
to a small group of Market actors which
actually rejected the 1776 Vision that
every person's voice and vote ought to
count equally regardless of their
position in the marketplace for dollars
when it comes to political questions so
that's kind of what animated my journey
more than even just the idea of of
maximizing value though I though I do in
my capitalist capacity care about that
too it's actually my
indignation as a citizen I would say
that actually was what pushed me to take
all the steps I've taken in the last few
years
you're now running for president uh in
the 2024 election
before we talk about what your specific
views are and kind of what your campaign
is what is your analysis of the last I
don't know eight ten years of politics
we've had a Republican president we've
had a Democratic president we've had a
uh uh environment where there was low
interest rates we now have an
environment where there's High interest
rates if you've kind of seen a lot of
different things happen over that you
know call it decade or so what's worked
and what hasn't worked so far
so look I think that it's a direct
pickup from where I left off in my own
story what drives me to do this
is that it does take two to tango right
so everything we're talking about so far
was about a top-down cynical marriage of
business and government and there's
truth to all of this of course but that
only works if you have a culture and a
populace
that's really willing to buy up what
they're selling okay
that's something that no Market actor
alone can address if the demand side of
this is what it is and I think there's a
reality to that too and I just think so
I'll make a couple observations you
asked about the last 10 to 15 years
we're in the middle we're in the middle
of the largest intergenerational wealth
transfer in human history from Baby
Boomers to Millennials we've lived in an
era of chronic Easy Money artificially
created money raining from on high like
Mana from Heaven that has created a
culture in its wake that leaves actually
not just a cultural vacuum but a moral
vacuum of people forgetting what actual
productivity what actually drives
productivity and long-run economic
Prosperity because of the artificial
snow that we've been skiing on as the
artificial snow machine now turns off we
forget how to actually do the real thing
but all of that has contributed to what
I see as a national identity crisis
we're you know our generation let's call
it right millennial you know ish
um whatever are millennials and younger
but really any generation in America
today
we're so hungry for a cause we're so
hungry for purpose and meaning
and identity in this country
at a point in our history where the
things that used to fill that void
whatever it was I mean maybe it was
religion family hard work national
identity
those things have disappeared they're
uncool they're not popular but we still
have that black hole in Need for purpose
and so we fill it
we fill that hunger with fast food
instead maybe it's wokism maybe it's
gender ideology maybe it's covetism
maybe it's climatism
these are just secular religions that
are filling the need to believe in
something higher at a point when we've
lost our ability to believe in something
higher
so the whole premise of my candidacy and
I'm not I'm running as a republican but
I'm not a I'm not partisan politics guy
I could care less for the Machinery of
partisan politics I think it's it's at
best boring and at worst even
unproductive
but I'm running on a premise of Reviving
that missing national identity to fill
that void that black hole
with the ideals that set this particular
nation into motion 250 years ago from
unbridled meritocracy to free speech
open debate Democratic self-governance
over aristocracy
these are ideas that I I'm pretty
convinced convinced most Americans
actually agree on
I think most Americans are pretty sure
their neighbors and their colleagues
agree on them too but they're not sure
anymore
because they don't feel free to talk
about it and my whole premise is if
we're able to talk about this in the
open if we're able to take down the
conversational barriers we will discover
that the real dividing line in America
is not today between Democrats and
Republicans which would make it sort of
a 50 50 thing
but it's between those who are members
of this artificial managerial class
and the everyday citizen who's crushed
by the will of that managerial class or
a different way of cutting the cake is
pro-american as defined by pro-american
values the values that I just laid out
or a subset of this country that's
anti-American in the sense that they
fundamentally oppose those ideals in
which this country was founded and those
transcend the boundaries of partisan
politics but the beauty of that I think
is that the split isn't 50 50 anymore I
think it's like 80 20. which is why I
think 2024 Canon should be a landslide
election
Reagan style 1980 1984 style election
and I'm running to deliver it I think we
can but I think we're gonna have to look
beyond the the
you know
suffocating
confines of identity politics or
partisan politics to do it and so that's
the the first six months of this is
laying out that cultural Vision so when
I hear uh national identity I think uh
it's this message of like proud to be an
American right and uh something about
the city of Miami specifically is uh it
is this uh Melting Pot of people from
all different walks of life all
different geographies uh there are tons
of people from uh south of Central
America from Europe uh from other areas
of North America from Africa India
middle I mean you just go across the
entire Globe people end up here and
what's so fascinating about this to me
is that as all those people come
together there is this feeling that what
it means to be an American in a city
like Miami may actually be different
than what it means to be an American
somewhere else but that Pride still cuts
through all those different communities
and so when you think of that what does
that future look like if more and more
of the citizens not only feel the
internal Pride to be an American but
they're willing to speak about it to
their neighbors they're willing to uh
post about it on social media they're
willing to say hey these are the ideals
and values that I stand for and I'm
willing to defend them yes when somebody
violates them what does that future look
like in America well I think I think
it's a beautiful thing that you
described I mean I'm a kid of immigrants
as well my parents came from India not a
lot of money 40 years ago but we have a
certain love of the country that
I wouldn't say that you could only have
as a first generation American or an
immigrant but that you definitely can
have especially as somebody who opted to
be part of this or who's the kid of
someone who opted to be part of this
made a sacrifice to be part of this you
don't just always value something you
inherit you often value something you
had a stake in choosing you had a stake
in building
but I think our diversity is only
beautiful
if it is against the backdrop of
something greater that unifies us across
that diversity without that
I'm looking across the audience here
okay well I've got a lot of shades of
melanin that's great
who cares if we're just a bunch of
different looking four-legged or
two-legged higher mammals roaming a
common Geographic space doing what
iPhones tell us to do on a given day
sometimes I wake up that's what America
looks like to me and and we're
celebrating diversity as our strength I
think the whole thesis of my candidacy
is that diversity I will say this out
loud and we deserves to be said
diversity is not our strength
our strength is what unifies us across
our diversity what unifies our across
our diversity in this country is the
ideals that we share goes to our
Humanity because what makes us different
than four-legged beasts or even
two-legged ones that roam a geographic
spaces that we can believe in an ideal
that's what makes us human beings so it
gives us our humanity and the thing that
makes American identity so beautiful is
it's it's tied to the essence of what
makes us human beings themselves worthy
of respect and so
what does that world look like looks
like one in which you see that
commonality first before you see the
difference in the shade of your melanin
content my last book actually the nation
of victims we talked to it's just a Side
Story just reminded me of as we were
talking now
septimius Severus actually he wasn't a
great Roman Emperor but he was a Roman
Emperor nonetheless
he he happened to have dark skin okay so
some streaming Network I don't know if
it was HBO or whoever it was some of
these streaming Networks
a couple of years ago or a decade ago
creates a show calling him celebrating
him as the black Emperor
the first man who came to England black
man to come to England came not as a
slave but a conqueror and built him up
as his hero figure
turns out if you lived in the Roman era
they didn't see him as a black Emperor
at all I mean they had eyes they could
see that he had darker skin but it was
the same way that we look at somebody
who has dark different shade of their
eye color right it was just a biological
fact about them
and I think that if we can go to get to
a place where okay I see it and even
even one step further there may be a lot
of cultural diversity it's part of that
but the thing I see is what the Romans
saw is that you were a citizen now the
irony about September Severus is that
they're building them up as the black
Emperor he's actually one of the most
brutal Emperors because he conquered
other Empires including those of other
black Africans from who he whom he
plundered why was he plundering because
Roman Empire was in Decline and he
actually was the one who diluted the
Daenerys the most right printing
artificial money a lesson we can learn
too inflated the currency he did
something that we don't do which is
plunder somebody else's silver to be
able to actually fill the void but
that's a Side Story just so people are
educated about that Emperor I'm not
building him up to be some hero figure
but it's interesting that that's the way
a Roman saw fellow Roman as a citizen
and for most of my life that's how
fellow Americans see each other as a
fellow citizen but we have been
acculturated to see each other now as
the amalgam of our boring genetic
attributes
and I think we can get back to that but
it's going to take some leadership and
it's going to take cutting through this
culture of fear I see that Culture of
Fear in the Republican party too so one
of my one of my first things I'll do as
president I've committed to this is
something a president can do end
affirmative action in this country
you're not supposed to say that out loud
thank you I appreciate that race-based
affirmative action is a National Cancer
it's not just about anti-black
anti-white or anti-asian racism it is
that but it's more than that it's
fueling a new wave of anti-black racism
in this country I truly believe that
because there's no better way to Foster
racial animus against a group than to
take something away from a different
group on the basis of their skin color
we've done it in 1870 we've done it in
1840 we're doing it in 2023.
and and yet I mean even Donald Trump you
know this is one that he could I mean so
Lyndon Johnson said this executive order
into motion not a lot of people know
this like like many bad things that
started with the federal government
it was an Executive Order 11246 in in
you know the 60s
that required anyone who does business
with the federal government so that
includes 20 percent of the U.S Workforce
by the way not a lot of people knows I
mean GM does business with the federal
government Google does business with the
federal government 20 of the US
Workforce to adopt race-based quota
systems as a condition from being able
to do business any U.S president since
then could have taken a pen and crossed
it out because that's an executive order
and even Republicans they delicately
dance around this one Trump could have
done it I've actually pushed some of his
team on why they didn't do it long
before I was running for president he
said well it's not a political Hill that
we want to die on
and you know I think sometimes the
Republicans of today look a lot like
Teddy Roosevelt's worst nightmare you
know speak loudly and carry a small
stick and I think that when it comes to
our culture we got to speak loudly and
carry a big stick I think that's the
moment we're in now
but I think taking on some of these
sacred cows you're not supposed to touch
from affirmative action uh to climate
religion which I'm unapologetically uh
someone who resists the demands of this
religion uh to you know I think we we
should celebrate our ability to live a
high carbon lifestyle in fact the rest
of the world should only be so lucky the
best known way to lift people up from
poverty is indeed the use of the
resources and The Innovation that has
allowed us to use carbon in the way we
have to enter the use of the military to
protect the Border who had ever thought
a U.S military protects a U.S border
rather than somebody else's border you
know solve a cartel problem if you're
going to designate them domestic Terror
if you're going to designate them
terrorists don't just freeze their
assets if you think bin Laden's a
terrorist you took them out you think
Solomon is a terrorist you take them out
you think a drug cartel is behaving
exactly the way Al Qaeda and Isis did
why is that anathema
it is to the modern defense
establishment but I don't understand why
it is and the more I've studied the more
convinced I've become that these are
things that we ought to be doing
these aren't even partisan ideas though
the Republic I was just came from CPAC
and I will tell you uh they were eating
it up you guys are like very polite they
were rambunctious uh last night but but
the conservatives like it but but I
think these are not fundamentally
partisan ideas I think most most
Independents and I think many Democrats
increasingly quietly but nonetheless
agree they'll agree more quietly behind
closed doors but I think if we are able
to
tear down the illusion of division and I
do think it's a it's an illusion created
by those who who profit from it
either in actual dollar terms or in
political terms then I think we
ReDiscover that that reality that future
world that we talked about where we see
one another as
fellow citizens who share a commitment
to a set of ideals it's not some distant
future it's just right here sitting in
front of us we just have to open our
eyes and see it and I'm hoping over the
next year and a half and then the next
48 years after that that's that's going
to be my small role in driving a
something of a cultural Revival in this
country when I think of uh proud to be
an American it signifies to me you can
be proud of a lot of things you can be
proud of uh your family where you work
the community you're in uh various
social groups you're in ETC but being
proud doesn't necessarily make you
immune to critiquing those groups as
well sure and so you can be proud of
something let's say you're on a sports
team but you also have to critique
yourself because that's the only way you
can get better and one of the things
that you've already laid out is that
there's a number of organizations in the
federal government that you think that
we can do without and so the one that I
think you've been kind of most vocal
about so far is the Department of
Education talk a little bit as using
that as an example in terms of going
into what many people would say is a
kind of over budget bureaucratic uh
inefficient system and organization how
do you pick what goes what stage yeah
and then how do you fight against the
inertia of the system as president
so so I have views on the latter but let
me just talk about
the vision of how I see the
administrative state three categories in
the way I look at what I expect you as
president all right so one is agencies
that never should have existed that
still exist but better late than never
shut it down and make it a dividend to
the people if needed so about 80 billion
dollars or run through the Federal
Department of Education
you divide 80 billion dollars across a
lot of the underfunded Public Schools
across the country that adds up to a lot
of money okay you do the math on a
district by District basis but it's not
just the money it's the fact that when
you have a centralized body
with tens of thousands of bureaucrats
who come to work for literally no good
reason they find things to do and that's
actually the source of a lot of the
emergence of gender ideology and
critical race ideology in the schools is
it's a string attached to accepting that
Federal funding so the first thing I've
said I'll do is I will shut down the
Department of Education and that's in
category a well I'll shut it down and
it's not going to come back
category B are functions that much more
limited set but functions that do need
to exist
but that have become just the
bureaucracy like that literally that
organization has become so toxic in its
ossified managerial bureaucratic insular
perspective and operation that the only
way to reform it is not through actual
putting a figurehead on top or hiring
new people it's just so much a part of
the DNA of that bureaucracy that you
have to shut it down and then replace it
with something new built from scratch a
true startup to take place the incumbent
that you level I put the FBI in that
category it is still the J Edgar Hoover
building that those people walk into
every day and whether it was
60 years ago when Democrats wanted to
end it or whether it's 60 years later
when a broader group of Americans who
lean in a different direction want to
end it
I think that better late than never
shut the FBI down
create something new to actually take
its place that has Integrity to its
actual purpose of enforcing the laws
rather than to be the nation's
determiners of who actually runs the
country and viewing the president as an
employee
and then I think there's there's a third
category of agencies that do lend
themselves to reform some cases radical
reform I put the FED in this category
right the U.S federal reserve needs a
different fundamentally different
mandate than it has today so it's an
organization where here so category 8
shouldn't exist in the first place
category B
needs to exist a law enforcement
function but is so corrupt and so
ossified that you just gotta shut it
down and then create something new
category C is okay if I was drawn up the
system in the first place I wouldn't
have included a Federal Reserve but I
would say that for Every Nation on Earth
so if we're just accepting some
realities That central banks exist still
need a radical reform of the mission of
the Federal Reserve
and and here I mean this I I guess we're
talking to a money crowd here so I think
it's okay uh to go into detail if I'm
getting boring then just let's keep
moving on but I just think they want to
hear about the you sure okay all right
you know remains open so we can keep we
can move on but I I think the myth of
the Phillips curve is itself an
artificial construct created by faulty
academic premises based on Old British
data that actually were not at all
extrapol to a modern economy let alone
an American one that say there's a
fundamental trade-off between inflation
and full employment
it's just it's just an entire agency an
entire apparatus in the U.S and then the
rest of the globe too operating on one
giant faulty premise that makes a
central bank fundamentally hostile to
Full Employment because full employment
to them is a signal of inflation which
means you have to do the opposite thing
so anyway I think the job of the Federal
Reserve to the extent we have one and I
think I'm a pragmatist as well I'm not
just spouting off ideas the things I say
we're going to do we're going to do
is not I'm going to say I'm not going to
shut down the fed or anything else
somebody who says that don't believe
them but dramatically restrict the scope
of the Federal Reserve to be exclusively
about doing one thing
make the dollar a unit of measurement
Peg it to a basket of currencies and
your job is to maintain a stable dollar
period that's it and I think that that
is a disciplining function
but it's also one that you know none of
us should know that Jerome Powell is the
chair of the FED we it it should not be
a thing that most Americans know there's
a lot of things Americans should know
that they don't but this shouldn't be
one of them and I think that it should
either the foot is a unit of measurement
to the meter in the same way that the
dollar is a unit of measurement to a
basket of Commodities okay
so anyway back to your point that'd be
my vision there's three categories for
bureaucratic reform the how of how you
do it
I I take a strong view of this thing
called the Constitution which says the
executive branch is led by the elected
president of the United States
well I'll bring a private sector
perspective to an interpretation of the
Constitution and I'm not just winging it
I also went to law school but but I
think this is a more useful lens to
bring to this here
is that
if someone works for you and you can't
fire them
that means that they don't work for you
it means you are their slave actually
because
you're responsible for what they do
without having any authority over what
they do
and so what happens today is the
president of the United States is
basically a slave of the administrative
state but he gets to live in the White
House to compensate for it like that's
effectively the way this works
and I don't intend to be the fool who
runs to be the next puppet who occupies
that office but I think the key is even
others who have said things like this
and meant it in case of trump or
whatever is
they believe that Congress had to act
and became frustrated that Congress
doesn't repeal Civil Service protections
or impoundment prevention protections
which say that if Congress allocates
money to a specific agency the president
actually has to spend it or Federal
Union protections and my view is you
don't have to
go through Congress on this stuff
because article two of the Constitution
says that the president runs the
executive branch and the common plain
text understanding of that bringing this
private sector novel idea that I said if
somebody works for you can fire them
means that you can actually fire
somebody who works for you this will be
litigated but I've also studied the
current composition of the Supreme Court
and you know what well I can't say this
with certainty it is my belief that a
majority of this Supreme Court unlike 20
years ago agrees with this
interpretation of the Constitution which
means we codify this in judicial
precedent so that not only through my
presidency but every presidency here and
after
the person who actually runs the country
will be the people who the citizens
elect to run the country who would have
ever thought that was actually the way a
self-governing democracy worked and yes
I think it can be so again so that's
that's a top domestic priority agenda
for me thank you
when you decide to run for president
how much of it is uh I am looking at the
state of the United States I have a
vision for improving it iterating it to
something that I want to see exist in
the world
combined with
who is in political office who are other
people who are running when you kind of
view this I don't think anyone else here
has ever run for president or gone
through the analysis of doing it how
much is just like the job versus people
that are either also going to run
currently in various offices like talk a
little bit as to how you kind of view
that so I can't can't speak for others
I'll speak for myself my sense is that
the answer is different for others
especially those who are professional
politicians
um I think their answer will be probably
the inverse of what mine is mine is 90
the first right it's I have a Clear
Vision for the country it's not somebody
else's Vision hand it to me in a binder
for better or worse it is a vision that
I've developed over the course of three
books I've written in the last 18 months
traveled the country been to a majority
of States listened to large audiences
respond to my message and learn more
from them in response
and I think we have a national identity
crisis that Demands a vision so that's
what guided me into this regardless of
of who else is is running
and as recently as November as recently
as Thanksgiving if you told me that I
was going to do this I would have said
that that was
a crazy idea but there was something
about it
that just I felt called you know in the
month of December over Christmas break
we just took a long hard think about as
much as I'm going to work on these top
down issues even through the market it
does take two to tango there is this
culture that
is a separate you know an economic terms
demand side problem here that needs to
be addressed now ten percent of it
though is I think part of what made it
click for me was also watching the
beginning of the Republican field shape
up to what appeared to be a
Collision Course towards a biographical
brawl between Trump and DeSantis
which I think would have just been shame
for the country to make it a tug of war
about personalities and some sort of
you know ego driven dispute I'm not
saying that that's exactly where where
it was or is even now but that was that
was where it was heading whereas to me
this ought to have been and now will be
about substance about competing Visions
for the country it's not about me it's
not about Trump it's not about DeSantis
I don't even think 2023 there aren't
going to be any votes cast it shouldn't
even be about the who should be about
the what and the why what do we stand
for
why do we stand for it answer that
question
and then the who becomes a lot easier in
the Republican party of today gets
obsessed over this question of the who
is it Kevin McCarthy or somebody else
that's a week of news cycle Rana
McDaniel or somebody else and if those
of you don't know who that is good for
you but you know you know so Donald
Trump or somebody else you know this is
this is the obsession of a Republican
party that's just it's just a symptom of
the fact that
it's a party that doesn't even know what
it actually stands for right and and so
I think that defining that agenda and
that Vision makes the selection of the
who a lot easier the premise of our
campaign strategy is that look the
person who leads the way in defining
that agenda this year will be selected
by the voters of this country to
implement that agenda next year I don't
know if that premise is right or not but
I think it is uh and that's that's
certainly our entire campaign strategy
is built around leading that
Vision leading the definition of the
agenda this year what it means to be a
republican what it means to be an
American
and then our expectation is that next
year that will lead to me being the
nominee and hopefully if my analysis
situation is right of the 80 20 divide
rather than the 50 50 divide we win 2024
in the landslide
but uh you know there's a lot of steps
to get from here to there but it's you
got a personal question what does it
feel like it feels like you're jumping
off of a cliff into an abyss you don't
know exactly where you're going to land
it's a sacrifice but you can always make
a sacrifice if you know what you're
actually sacrificing for uh you know
this is going to be a bottom-up campaign
because I've had financial success and I
don't apologize for it I'm making a
significant personal investment behind
this but the good news is people don't
from Michael Bloomberg on to you know
anybody else who's learned this lesson
Coke you know to anybody else over the
years you don't buy elections in this
country that's just to get this movement
started this is going to be bottom up uh
and I actually think I know this is not
a you know crypto audience per se but I
know you have an interest in the space
and and actually developing crypto
policy is an important part of what my
team's working on right now but this is
bottom up and so I'm I've learned not to
be Shameless about this in nine days on
the campaign honestly check out what I'm
saying
2024.com v-i-v-e-k
2024.com and actually the thing that
determines that the Republican party is
weirdly non-transparent about this stuff
but the one thing we know is that
placement on the debate stage and how
much time you get Etc is going to be
driven by almost certainly unique donor
counts so not how much money alone but
the number of unique donors like
seriously you don't have to vote for me
put a dollar put five dollars in and
that ensures that we at least Define the
agenda and I think that that's what not
only the Republican party needs but the
country needs more of
and I hope that we will on the other
side of this be actually unified around
the vision of e pluribus unum it's on
all of our coins for a reason and you're
right I loved what you said earlier
patriotism and loving America isn't just
about F-16 fighter jets and Eagles and
red white and blue and celebrating that
it's not actually it's about a
recognition of Who We Are
and you know even recognizing the best
Arguments for the woke movement or
whatever is acknowledging our hypocrisy
or whatever I don't reject that premise
actually far from it I think our
hypocrisies our worst hypocrisies are
our best proof of the fact that we have
ideals at all
okay nobody will ever call the Chinese
Communist Party hypocritical you can
call them a lot of things but you can't
call him hypocritical if they don't have
ideals and they don't right you can only
be a hypocrite if you had ideals in the
first place and our worst hypocrisies
are the proof that we have those ideals
and also are the proof that we are human
beings who by definition will forever
fall short of our ideals but America is
about the pursuit of those ideals and I
just think if we can use even the last
10 years not just to do what even a lot
of people on my side of the political
aisle like to do which is you know I
think be aggrieved by the existence of a
culture that's gone in the wrong
direction but instead view it as an
opportunity to be even strengthened by
going through something of a you know
National adolescence
I don't think we have to be
post septimius Severus Rome I don't
think we have to be in some inevitable
National decline
I think that we might just be a little
young
going through our version of adolescence
figuring out who we really are and
that's okay
as long as we actually live to grow up
on the other side of it and that's what
I'm hoping 2024 actually represents is
an entry into a sort of cultural
adulthood in our country that we've long
missed and so anyway at the very least
the next milestone for us is elevating
these ideas on the debate stage defining
that agenda and if the entire world of
crypto I think got behind this I think
there's also going to be a crypto policy
agenda that I think will be far more
sensible than what either of the sides
of the aisle is going to put on offer
I'll actually take a lot of help from
whoever you think are smart folks on
that we're working on that as we speak
the only thing I want is a mass movement
of people who put in a dollar or five
dollars to actually make sure that we
drive the agenda this year and then
hopefully put ourselves in a position to
win next year how can people follow you
on Twitter you've been posting a
amazing amount of content in terms of
videos conversations some of it is right
after you have a meeting like you're
very kind of open and transparent about
the process of doing this your ideas
various speeches where can I follow you
on Twitter yes it's at you know handle
thing you know Vivek G ramaswamy spelled
the usual way uh you know but but uh
but I'll say this is actually one one
cool thing we're going to start doing on
the campaign uh next week or the week
after is probably the week after uh is
there's this charade actually I feel
compelled to share this with everyone
there's a charade in being a
presidential candidate the charade is
this you get these briefings before you
go speak to an audience or do a
interview with a reporter which like
brief you on some Topic in like the
Middle East that you didn't know the
first thing about until like 30 minutes
before the interview and then you get
the bullet points and then you sort of
you know puff your chest in and project
as though you knew this all your life it
is just false it is hilarious uh but
it's but it is also fundamentally false
and so one of the things that we're
doing is we're taking all of my
briefings which are hopefully going to
be daily for me that's also just a
disciplining function because one of the
things is just time expands and even
just this first 10 days of campaign the
one thing I miss is learning new things
we've just been stacked I was in DC this
morning I'm here we're popping to Palm
Beach for like a you know big Republican
event down there
I don't have I I'm gonna get back to
this this week There's a forcing
function of just learning new things
every day and so we're just going to
open source that briefing process
everyone else can learn in the same way
but also hopefully evaluate a candidate
not just on what they already know which
is in reality what they pretend to know
but actually I think probably one of the
most important attributes of a president
is to understand how they learn so we'll
put that out through social media I will
try to make good use of our website as
well uh so we're we're trying to direct
most people is the website which is
vivek2024.com but Twitter is another
place where we'll be we'll be posting a
lot of this I I put vivek2024.com
because that has a nice little donate
tab at the top so people people do like
one dollar even so so that's that's kind
of like why we push people there but uh
but we'll through all you know it'll be
through whatever other social media
channels we're going to be as wide and
far-reaching as we can to literally open
up the process so people can actually
understand what this process entails
because I'm just 10 days in to this
everything I thought it was it was just
is just artificial it's made up it's
it's an it's a fake projection but I
hope that gives the other candidates
Comfort too to be a little bit more real
I've given a challenge to the GOP field
uh you know we all a couple of us spoke
at CPAC yesterday they didn't follow my
challenge but I keep pressing them on it
no third-party written speeches
disintermediate the political
Consultants who try to
channel the message no it's just
actually a a shielding process no
third-party written speeches no
teleprompters no reading from speeches
make that rule that'd be your first time
in politics so I don't I've committed
I'm not using teleprompters not having
any written speeches but we want to push
the other candidates to do the same
thing but I think the more we hopefully
lead by example I hope the more of that
we actually get from the other
candidates so that that's a change
that'll outlive this election
if we actually just change the rules of
the road of how how the sausage gets
made
ladies and gentlemen Vivek ramashwami
thanks guys appreciate it
thank you appreciate it